there we go should be it right
hello hello hello yeah we got it cool
cool
okay there we go
everybody there everything went out it
went out it went out
cool
okay yeah it's good though
uh i might
do miss marvel
after kenobi
on other dates
probably not tonight because i gotta fly
to la tomorrow
uh so that's a lot that's a lot on my
plate tonight
so most likely not gonna watch miss
marvel tonight sorry
because i've already i've seen the first
two episodes
it's morphin time
disneyplus.com is not working
oh there it is
i did the polls uh
excuse me
uh we did the polls on twitter we did
the polls on instagram
or not instagram uh last time we were on
youtube live uh
seems like people wanted
to do kenobi
so that's what we're doing
what the heck
i can't log into
i can't log into
disney plus
yeah then we have black adam in the
morning
and now i can't figure out my password
for disney plus what the heck
all right i forgot password
that didn't
it didn't do anything
uh disney plus is not uh
is not being friendly tonight
not at all
it's not even like loading for me
it's not letting me run into it's not
even letting me
go to the login page now well all right
i can watch it on my uh
i can watch it on my
laptop if i have to
yeah it's not going to be out until like
15 minutes uh
yeah
yeah i mean miss marvel's gonna be cool
um
it's gonna connect a lot you'll see a
lot of connections right away you know
dude why isn't disney plus working holy
crap
it's not working for
me that's unfortunate
hello fire cat hello everybody
disney plus not morbid
it's not even well it's not even letting
me log in now it's not even about being
able to log or not even about forgetting
my password now she's not even letting
me log in
yeah everything else is working
everything else is working
hmm
let's just keep trying it
it's better than a kids show um it's
it's tailored i would say towards a
younger audience but not necessarily
kids
it's not going to be like the
teletubbies
no it's not cringe but it's a younger
humor you know
well uh i
can pull it up on my laptop here
let's see if it's working on my laptop
it's not it's barely working on my
laptop am i i am signed in though no i
don't want to watch a fan's guide to
miss marvel
i know who miss marvel is
miss marvel miss marvel
see this should be like the first thing
that pops up
when i log in and it's not
it's going to make me search it
miss marvel
yeah it's there
oh yeah
oh it took a while for you mr anderson
yeah mine's not working it's not even
on my computer it's not even letting me
go to the login page
which is annoying as hell
come on
i mean it works on my
it works on my laptop so i can always do
that
we can always do that
oh wait oh no we're we're watching
episode four if you know me tonight i
was gonna say
wait it's already out
yeah i will say
i mean miss marvel was like very
different um
which isn't a bad thing
right it's good for marvel to have a
change of pace and everything like that
like you know
it's not bad it's not bad you know
your disney plus took about 10 seconds
to open mine uh
mine's not even opening it open on my
laptop i don't know why it's not working
on my computer it's kind of annoying
hmm everything else seems to be working
just fine
doesn't want me to do it
oh oh here we go okay okay okay okay
here we go
password's not correct forgot password
okay okay here we go
we're getting somewhere we're getting
somewhere we're getting somewhere okay
four six two two four two
you use what password
what
it's saying
it just it's trying to get me
to log
what
this is so weird
lou sasso happy birthday
and thank you wesley will
you have a good friend lou
but happy birthday to you i hope uh
i hope it's a really good one
what is happening
what
i'm curious what email do i use
oh that is a that is a different email
okay that is not the right email
that's that's the problem
but it said my email was wrong for that
too am i
there it is
cool
we're in finally jeez that took forever
alright laptop you were not needed this
second
how much more time before obi-wan comes
out
nine
minutes disney has been uh
they've been pretty good
at dropping things right at 11 50. my
chair won't move back like right at 11
15. they've been really good at that
so
that seems to be the k that seems to be
what's going to keep going on
yeah so it's disney plus is going to be
overwhelmed tonight i bet because miss
marvel and obi wan
so
miss marvel's gonna be good um we're
gonna finish obi-wan before we dive into
our miss marvel watch parties
but if you're watching miss marvel and
you're just in this chat feel free to
feel free to talk about that as well
uh i'm i am genuinely genuinely curious
about uh
what people think of miss marvel um
i know some people
think it
some people said it like sucks
but then today i saw that like it's got
a rotten tomatoes review of like 96 or
something like that so i'm like i guess
not a lot of people think it sucked and
i saw the first two episodes and i
thought they were fine like
not everything has to be on such a
massive scale like you know we always
expect from the mcu i mean it's nice
right but that's what the movies are for
i think these disney plush shows are
really cool because they they let you
really dive into the story of like these
new heroes so i'm sure people love it
i'm sure people will hate it i'm sure
people will be in between i'm kind of in
between i'm here for the ride i think
it's an enjoyable show i think there are
some funny parts of the show and i like
the vibe of the show i actually really
like the vibe and the animation of the
show so
i enjoy it
is it the greatest thing ever
no but some people might think it is and
that's okay
perfectly okay
i'm curious to see what you all think
really curious to see what you guys
think
some maybe
maybe next week we can do both
watch parties for both but uh
i have to fly to la tomorrow early in
the morning
so
it's gonna be really hard to do both
tonight
man these morbius memes are really
i'd be shocked if they made morbius too
i really would be shocked
like i think they'll make it eventually
down the road
but i think
i think marvel studios has to do it
like i think marvel studios has to do
more bs for it to be successful
hey enchantrix how's it
going was i pursuing with my psych major
nicholas i actually went to graduate
school for like
three semesters
um
and
i was gonna go for my phd and i wanted
to be a psychologist and then i debated
being a psychiatrist
uh but then i started a company with my
dad and
i have a very long story
uh
maybe i'll tell it one day but uh i
wanted to be either a psychologist or
psychiatrist wesley wu thanks for that
super chat can i do a video on my stream
set up sometime yeah sure
um i just got a whole brand new setup
from elgato so i'm really really happy i
can actually control everything
from this oh the cable's not long enough
ah from this it's my stream deck
the casing is falling off
whoopsies oh it's magnetic oh that's
even cooler
so yeah i could do
there we go
i can do something
oh easy did your social worker nice nice
nice nice
i feel like
i know sony's not ever gonna sell like
their rights to like
all this stuff right but i mean i feel
like they should
like i really feel like they should
i feel like they're
not selfish prideful
prideful is that
it's probably the right word i feel like
they're a little prideful i feel like
they're like really trying to
like say we can do it like
marvel can do it but we can do it too
you know what i mean with our properties
that we have especially since they won't
give them back
so hey shane how's it going morita
shane
thanks for super chat um well we just we
watch together and
we kind of share our thoughts as we
watch it i wish i could show it on
screen but i can't because of the
copyright
but we kind of just enjoy it together
and then share our thoughts afterwards
so
hope you enjoy it hope you participate
arenziy hooks thank you very much i'll
use that two bucks for brunch
uh israel overpossessive
maybe uh
i i think it's like
a desire to prove themselves is what i
think it is i think it's like
because they know what we say they know
we wanted to go back to uh
uh marvel studios who say star wars
they know we wanted to go back to marvel
studios so
i feel like they're like no like we can
do it don't worry about it like we'll
show you like we'll show you that we can
do it and these characters are going to
be great and stuff like that
which anybody would feel that way right
that's how you would feel you would want
to make it better and do it better i
just don't think they have good people
in charge like
i don't think they have
creative people in charge and morbius
that kind of got screwed up because of
the pandemic and everything like that i
mean you know that's
what can you do right reshoots and sony
wanted to change things and they took
the spider-man stuff out and then they
threw that weird spider-man thing in at
the end and all that stuff like that i
mean in the in the post credit it was
like oh i think i have something to do
with spider-man's like you're gonna
casually brush that off and mention that
it's like that's so weird that's such a
weird strategy
but
maybe maybe something happens and maybe
maybe they get good like i i would like
to see the sony spider-verse succeed i
really would i just i haven't you know
and like the venom movies are really fun
they're really fun movies and there's a
lot of awesome parts to them
uh you know but they're not by any means
you know like avengers movies or
anything like that they're super fun
they're super awesome to watch i love
them i love the minute movies but you
know what i mean
so
i don't know
uh thoughts on marvel spider-man 2
uh let checks uh that's confusing
because they're all marvel you talking
about marvel studios spider-man 2 which
would be far from home or are you
talking about
spider-man 2 toby mcguire spider-man 2
with toby mcguire is one of the best
spider-man movies
the amazing spider-man 2 i don't like so
much
it has really great moments
and far from home is a great movie i
really like far from home so
i hope that answers your question i
answered all i answered for all three of
them because i didn't know which one you
were talking about um
potato chip i actually don't watch the
boys
it's a little too raunchy for me i'm not
a blood and guts fan and stuff like that
uh
got you confused with cosmic culture
well i found i founded cosmic culture i
started cosmic culture and then chris
who edits for cosmic wonder
um
i i let him take over
so it's okay if you're a little bit
confused
we are
we come from the same
what do we call like click crew crew
because we call it the cosmic crew so
all right kenobi
oh i got to do like a
a timer right
kenobi episode 4 is out i will do a
what is it what do i always do stopwatch
is that what i do stop yep stop watch
all right we're about to start our watch
party for kandobi in five
four
three
two
one go
39 minutes long
make it so i can still see the chat here
i can't hear it
there we go
where's my right there it is
cool
i hope tala lives
that is one thing that i want i i really
i really really really want tala to live
dude vader was savage
i am what you made me that was really
cool
let me pause the timer for a second
because i'm at
160
19
20. there it is it's on time
oh yeah a little late i got captured by
riva
all right here we go
i also really love the new i mean it's
not new they've done it for years now
but the star wars like intro where they
show like darth vader
stormtrooper
droids you know what i mean c-3po kylo
ren r2d2 mandalorian
let's do it let's do it let's do it
pull up the chat on my phone because i
can't see it
i can't see it on
my computer because i'm watching obi-wan
i forgot what happened oh the droid took
him and tala took him right
oh and now he's burned
is that tala
dang
back to tank
oh
i would hate to be burned oh that's so
cool vader's in at the same time oh
i really i really like that
i really like that a lot
oh thanks ninja appreciate that
i mean he thought he killed him right
he cut off his limbs and he lit on fire
i definitely thought i killed him too
jabim
hey appreciate that ninja appreciate
that
thanks for the support hope you continue
to like this stuff
oh i thought she was gonna see vader i
was gonna say like dude did vader
actually meet leia
before you know
four five and six
she's so cute
you're a liar obi-wan's alive
oh
that's ice cube sun
he caught him general
oh she was a jedi
well so much for him being quinlan vos
there's
some theories about that today
or i guess over the past week
oh
he's down for the cause
he's close
no one would be stupid enough to attack
do it kenobi
oh tall you're gonna die aren't you i'm
gonna be so sad
oh that's true she does
i forgot yeah because she's empire
yeah it's ice cube's son isn't that cool
i actually saw him at the at the
premiere for obi-wan i was like five
feet away from him i wanted to start
rapping in wa but
i don't think he'd appreciate that
what
you're telling me you can't make a small
little thing move obi-wan i know you can
woof
she's too smart to fall for that
okay yeah israel i uh i'm hoping he gets
his groove back here pretty soon
he definitely does obviously by you know
the final episode but we're in four two
after this
this should be like a pretty
well next episode is gonna be the
pivotal episode but this one's gonna be
pretty uh
has her cover been blown will
will
they be force sensitive enough to
realize that
oh oh i saw people looking at her
the force is going to tell them that
that she betrayed
them i don't
weird
is it gonna say something
my favorite star wars movie oh bradley
that's a hard one
wait hold on what's happening here she's
red why is she showing up red
oh
i like it
nice
love it that's what i was thinking like
when she walked up i was like you gotta
be more confident and then she busted it
out love it
love it
you just gotta own it
you're right web i do feel like it's
fallen order
so
they i thought quinlan vos was going to
be i thought ice cube was going to be
quinlan boss
interesting oh what's that
interesting
yeah i mean she is an empire officer
right
but she said you know the empire
changed since when she signed up for it
alright obi
all right ben
time to use the force brother
oh bradley my favorite star wars movie
man uh
dude i i love revenge of the sith i
don't care what anybody says
that probably is my favorite star wars
movie
i love revenge of the sith man i just
there's always a bigger fish
oh please tell me she's not going to be
able to infiltrate her mind
this is daring contest
oh
lola
huh
don't break lola again
poor lolo
who are you we all want to know
what how was it taken you were a jedi
and during order 66 you joined the sith
right
pull the confidence card again
uh
uh
oh
oh he left she left it there oh that's
smart
that's smart to leave it there because
if she would have kept it on her
oh for sure by the end we're definitely
going to see his full powers jd
i'm wondering what happened i wonder
what happens this episode
i really hope tala doesn't die cuz like
i really felt like she's gonna die i
still kind of feel like it
oh snap
yo she's straight up just freaking
yo
she like snapped his neck
get it tala
hello adiqu hello hello
yeah use the force
yeah she is mr anderson
i had some company and i had to kill
them no big deal
all right sister three you're not gonna
break young leia but i do wonder if
she'll sense that she that lay is force
sensitive
yeah right jeff's words
that's a lie
you're a liar why do you lie liar
oof
oh
stormtroopers you're really gonna you're
really gonna torture a 10 year old girl
you feel good about that stormtrooper
you feel
good attaching a 10 year old girl to a
freaking
torture device
come on ben you gotta fight
oh snap oh is that quinlan
was that qu
is that quinlan
oh
that's not good
uh
enterisks dave we are watching
obi-wan episode four kenobi episode four
i couldn't make out who that was
can't make out who that is either
these are dead jedi
holy crap
i swear i thought i saw quinlan
are these all jedi i can't i can't tell
oh no
see kenobi this is why you gotta get
back this i think this is gonna kick
nobody back in shape shape
you're not sorry
hmm
awesome
oh that's cool
really stormtrooper you
you think you're the you think he's in
trouble and you're not that's funny
that's really cool though that's really
cool
the darkness and then the light that's
really cool kudos to that scene that was
a cool scene
uh he's alive but i think tala might be
dead dang
i'm worried for you ben i'm really
worried for talent
tally might be dead kyle's not dead yet
oh
oh
nice
nice
nice
yeah stormtroopers have never been the
uh most efficient
uh soldiers have they
leia lay on the floor
nice
lay on the floor leia
i love star wars music so much it's so
good
all right obi all right i'll just get it
back always get it back
there's nowhere to hide oh that's water
oh that's water
does this remind anybody of the ending
of uh
clone wars
huh
yep
use the force ben
it's always real smart building a
fortress under the water
where you have storm troopers with
freaking blasters who can't hit anything
all right ben time to go swimming
yeah jd he's getting better
tala you're supposed to run with leia
run run run
oh we're gonna see some four spot yeah
ben put the lightsaber up you gotta hurt
yourself
just retract it just retract it
uh clint that's an interesting question
i don't know if there's any
word of when do having a family jedi
aren't supposed to but who knows
i mean she could be sibling maybe but i
don't i don't i don't know i don't know
riva's thing i really don't
reba is revan i really hope not
darth revan is one of my favorites
don't be suspicious don't be suspicious
don't be suspicious don't be suspicious
oh
all right obi we're gonna need something
nope
i knew it i was gonna say
don't they they have oh look
look what ships they are i love it
i feel like it's a good time for a
lightsaber obi people are shooting at ya
but it's okay
i like the gunshots
yeah right shane
you build a whole entire fort just under
water
all right everyone
all right everyone
just jump on top of it just jump on top
of it just jump on top of it and leave
nice
i feel like wade's gonna die
you're dead wait oh
no you're dead
saw that coming from a very long way
away
were we supposed to know who these two
are i don't remember wade
i mean these are the people that
oh here's vader oh he pissed
yeah wouldn't it be crazy vader just
killed her
oh
oh
dude
because it's on the girl
because it's on leia
you're right the epic spire
so the tracker has to be on leia right
yeah
they lost weed
he did
dick
oh you're right mr anderson it's in lola
oh
no
it's on lola
oh
yeah she said where he goes
it will follow
and i thought she was referring to the
tracker and i thought she was referring
to leia because leia's you know
following
ben
but i mean that makes sense she puts in
the droid
we never saw her give it back to her
oh yeah they're gonna show us right here
yup
yup
there it
is there a post credit
i don't believe so
nope
dang
well what does everybody think of that
episode
i think i have cat hair in my mouth
huh
what'd you guys think
this was uh
there's a lot of really great parts of
this episode i really really liked i
really really liked it
that silver lining jar jar i wasn't in
the tomb yeah i couldn't
i couldn't make out who was in the tomb
hmm
i can't watch miss marlowe now guys i
gotta wake up early for a flight
uh next week i probably can watch both
um for sure
but
since i did a poll here last week
and then did a ball on twitter
a lot of people said
we want to watch kenobi over miss marvel
especially because when we in kenobi
will still have three episodes of miss
marvel left so we'll continue that
um
but man this was a
i like where the series is going i i
really want to say i really want to see
full strength kenobi and it looks like
he's definitely getting his his force
abilities back
yeah
yeah megan um i definitely get big
fallen order vibes from the show
hey tiggy thank you so much
uh
yeah i want to know too cardinals boy i
i couldn't make out
i couldn't really make out who was in it
um
i couldn't really make out any of those
jedi
and i don't know if they're i mean it
makes sense that they would all be jedi
was the little boy
no
was the little boy the boy that's like
master skywalker there too many of them
that wasn't him was it
no
i don't think so
uh
there was vader in this episode there's
a good vader scene
of course i kind of think any scene with
vader is a good scene so no there there
was a good there's a good vader scene
uh
sinoob
oh yeah
let's take a look at
i thought
was
was the first person they saw right
yeah yeah yeah yeah
terracinum yep
first person they saw
yep
i wonder who the kid was
oh yeah that is care
gender
yeah there was a there's a couple in
there
yeah
name a bad vader scene
yeah it's real
i think darth vader is one of the most
like
if not the most iconic villain of like
all time from just his suit the
breathing
the red lightsaber
the um the themes like the music all the
music that goes within the score like
i really
i like their name a more iconic villain
like
just
the silence
and then just like
like that
everyone knows what that is like
everyone knows that it is like you hear
that and you know it you look at like a
picture of darth vader even if you don't
really like know star wars or anything
like that you know that's darth vader
like
i don't think there's a more iconic
villain than darth vader i really don't
think so
i really really don't think so
so
yeah so clint and marvel dub yeah some
people are saying you know
um
riva could be a window which
would be pretty cool and i'm
trying to think back to like the second
episode
where she was trying to fight kenobi
was she gonna
was she gonna
kill him
i am really
interested in her backstory i am really
interested in her backstory
so
yeah joker you're you're right there
charlotte joker definitely definitely
but uh
yeah
underscore pm
thanks for super chat love this year so
far but in your honest opinion slightly
underwhelming so far vader is amazing
always though
uh
this would probably be the lesser of the
three episodes um i think the first two
were fantastic um
i love the series though so far um
so
yeah we'll see what happens
um
you think we'll get a spin-off of this
show i think we're gonna but i was there
at star wars celebration and um just the
way everybody talked they didn't reveal
too much but the way they talked it
sounded like a lot was coming so i'm
really excited for it i'm trying to do
you know more star wars my channel i'm
really excited that people are actually
supporting that because i know there's a
lot of people that are like oh i'm not
watching you anymore
you're not just doing marvel anymore but
i've never solely just done marvel it's
just what i like the best so
um
i mean everybody seems to think that
riva is gonna turn right i mean that
seems to be what the chat
really thinks here
except for mr anderson he'd like to see
arriva become stronger in the dark side
in a bigger villain
right lily's fandom mainly marvel that's
a great name yeah everyone recognizes
like darth vader's breathing and the
theme
[Music]
imperial march like
you know
cherub statues
there's no need for you van von yeah i
mean
but vader
doesn't want to do the grunt work you
know like he just wants to show up and
there's obi-wan he doesn't want to like
show up and have to track everybody down
and he doesn't want to have to deal with
uh
you know like
their team like the rebel resistance and
stuff like that you know what i mean
like the people that are gonna fight
uh
got rushed for hype
i
i really like the series i think they
killed it with the mandalorian boba fett
was pretty good although the best
episodes were with the mandalorian uh
but still great series um
so far i think it's really good again i
think this was a lesser of the three
series uh episodes but i do think that
uh
i think it's going to be really good i'm
i'm really liking the way it's going
i really like the way it's going
i'm really wondering i'm really
wondering what riva's backstory is
because the way you know they made it
sound and you know what we know about
inquisitors is you know
they're the jedi's are four sensitive
people who turn to the dark side so i'm
like
you did that by choice or she did it
because she had no choice right because
they would kill her anyways
so she's pissed at that
maybe she doesn't like the jedi maybe
she hates the sith at the same time
though
i'm [ __ ] i bet you
that we get riva's backstory next
episode
and the finale is
a big fight between her and kenobi and
then vader comes in she might die
you know
who knows
but i hope we find out
like who she is i'm sure we will so
yeah
yeah me too mr bean i i
hope they come in really really strong
uh super civic i i don't know if there's
gonna be a second series
maybe they have time you know
oh i'm tired
[Music]
kraku will show up and kill her if i
refuse to elaborate and leave
shows up kills are like
i'm out
so yeah but anyways y'all i have a an
early flight tomorrow to go to la i'm
going to the buzz lightyear premiere
um
and it seems like people are pretty
interested in that so i'll do a reaction
to that as well i'll put along the
channel
let you know my thoughts on it
so i'm going to that tomorrow and uh i
kind of got a place in l.a now
so i'm living there part-time
just for uh when i go to all these
events and stuff so i'm setting that
place up tomorrow as well so
long day tomorrow um plus you know i
gotta make some videos to put out
tomorrow so uh
yeah i will catch up with you all
tomorrow um
for whatever my you know video comes out
uh your three favorite disney series
loki mandalorian what if yeah loki is my
favorite
for sure for sure
but uh yeah okay so we'll pick up next
week and next week we'll also tackle
miss marvel at the same time can't do it
today because i'm just so tired and i
gotta wake up super early for a flight
so um
yeah look out for my video tomorrow i'm
not sure what i've decided to do it on
yet got a few good video ideas
and some news might come out so you
never never really know but thanks mr
anderson for being here
uh mr anderson has a channel two guys
he'll put that down he'll link it i'm
sure
um thanks for modding uh thanks for
everyone who was here thanks for all the
super chats the regular chats people who
are just watching it's a lot of fun um
we'll catch you next week and we'll we
will do obi-wan and then miss marvel
next week and i think
the episode two to miss marvel was like
15 minutes so it's gonna be a long week
next week it's gonna be a long week but
uh hey thank you all for being here love
you all three thousand and uh we'll
catch you next week when we go live
again alright